naturally as with any show focused on
two rival karate groups out for blood
and all valley tournament supremacy a
lot goes on in the final episode of
season four let's wax on and off about
cobra kai season 4 and what the upcoming
fifth could have in store as a result it
feels safe to say that the latest season
of cobra kai ends with an active
betrayal so great the lannisters could
have sent their regards after leaving
this year's tournament victorious and
seemingly putting both miyagido and
eagle fang out to pastor john crease
visits business partner terry silver to
discuss recent events and future plans
ever the entrepreneur silver takes
charge at the end of the championship to
announce cobra kai is branching out into
multiple schools around the valley to
push out the competition much decreases
frustration the difference of opinions
between these partners is the
culmination of the two growing further
apart in their independent visions after
an argument over the apparent breakdown
of their friendship and plans silver
reveals that the needs of cobra kai
outweigh whatever bond he has with his
old vietnam friend leading to a
finishing move kris never saw coming
after the latter rejects stingray's
attempt to return in an earlier episode
silver uses his pupils devotion to his
advantage before beating stingray
unconscious he offers stingray a second
chance if he names crease as his
attacker this leads to the arrest of the
og cobra for a crime he didn't commit
while silver takes the throne besides
second chances cobra kai is all about
finding balance even if that balance
happens to come from an opposing force
no two characters fit this bill better
than cobra kai's tory nichols and
miyagido team member samantha larusso
these young women are two sides of the
same coin and their showdown in season
four is one hyped up to incredible
lengths what is just as impressive
though is how much their fight paid off
and what it could mean for their ongoing
rivalry in season five with everything
riding on tori and samantha's final
battle at the all valley tournament in
season 4 the two contenders feel
pressured to perform no matter what side
of the mat they're on samantha struggles
to let go and do things her way while
tori learns to accept that her anger is
often her downfall by the end of the
match tori finds self-restraint even
going as far as to check on her opponent
much to samantha's surprise however what
is even more of a shock is that tori's
win is bought by terry silver and isn't
a legit victory who knows how the
unofficial winner will feel about her
match in the next season with so many
characters switching sides over the past
few seasons of cobra kai robbie keane
has felt like someone who's been caught
in the middle a lone warrior within the
ranks his struggle to keep a distance
between himself and possible allies
reached a breaking point when he fought
hawk and lost it is clear that robbie's
real battle is with himself seeing no
victory or anyone to turn to he finally
confronts the one battle he truly needs
to succeed the relationship with his
father finding johnny alone in the
former cobra kai studio robbie breaks
down in front of the dad he'd barely
spoken to since the start of copra kai
and reveals what is constantly beating
him down
i'm sick of blaming you death
it's a long overdue conversation that
will hopefully initiate a new era for
the pair on the show however while
johnny's relationship with this
biological sun is on the upswing the
same can't be said about the student
who's been like a son to him miguel has
always been the motivational through
lining cobra kai for johnny the daniel
to his miyagi their bond appears to grow
stronger this season when it is finally
revealed that johnny is seeing miguel's
mother which miguel accepts however he
can't accept johnny's obsession with
winning the tournament instead of
fighting the final match miguel leaves
the tournament and jumps on a bus to
mexico to find his father the rash
choice to get out of the valley leads
miguel's mother to make a desperate plea
for johnny to go after him could robbie
daniel and any of the rest of the corps
members come along for the ride at the
very least it seems like daniel will
have his own problems as the closing
shot sees him asking for chosen's help
in taking down cobra kai forever
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
cobra kai are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one